here's the Dark Side of crypto that
nobody talks about just the other week
$225 million of tether was frozen and
seiz the Department of Justice has been
working with tether to freeze all of
these funds that are supposedly
connected to illicit activity so when
people talk about crypto being
decentralized and censorship resistant
this is just not true tether is an erc20
stable coin built on the ethereum
network and the ethereum network is
actually highly centralized this means
all of the different crypto projects
built on the ethereum network like
tether will actually have to comply with
the United States government when the
government decides that they want to
shut it down